good afternoon everyone
thank you very much for coming um and
today's panels discussion is called
workplace culture
and mobility in time of change
my name is valentina donchevich from
design studio of alternative
and on behalf of paper space asia i'm
thrilled to be your host
today today's session will the panel
discussion will take approximately 40
minutes
after which we will go into q a session
and we're more than welcome to stay here
until 5 30 or so
so we can take our time with questions
and we have
online audience also and we're very
happy that
everybody who's joining in online so
please
welcome this is a second of
series of four panel discussions uh
we're conducting
alongside the exhibition we're holding
here at national design center
both panel discussions as well as the
exhibition
are created by paper space asia
and with support of design singapore
council
this is also part of the national design
center's casting hope
program for april and may this year
and our virtual audience today you're
very welcome
and please ask any questions you might
have
during the the entire discussion uh
online
due through to the module online
and our live audiences we will pass the
microphone
during the session so please feel free
to ask any questions you might have
we might extend our session but not to
worry we can stay here and afterwards we
will be
having some nice refreshments outside
now without further ado i will just give
you a very very brief
housekeeping matters we have two exits
here
one here and one at the back and also
please keep your masks on throughout the
discussion
as well as uh keep your one meter
distancing we just have to
i'm sorry about that um but i won't go
any further
and i'd love to introduce you to you
our panelists today
so we are very very pleased to have andy
andy schmidt
a ceo of six or eye communication
private limited in bringing the
swiss-made
employee application beekeeper to
singapore
andy helps organizations boost employee
engagement levels
of their frontline workforces
he was previously in multiple financial
roles
within the m c siemens for 23 years
next we have sherwin serger senior
vice president and head of people
experience
at prudential he is responsible for
driving
an inclusive work culture at prudential
enabling employees to reach their full
potential
his mandate includes culture
diversity and inclusion people
experience
workplace transformation digital hr
and hr service excellence sharing
formerly headed distribution business
management
at prudential a third
panelist is mark sharma
joint lead workplace strategy consulting
apec
region at jll mark has
over 25 years of experience in
integrated consulting
across the property life cycles
including portfolio strategy
workplace strategy change management
location advisory fm procurement
process and organizational design
this has included work across industries
worldwide such as financial services
pharma telecommunications and technology
fmcg and the public sector
[Music]
and today's today's
will be moderated by angelina das a
workplace change and communications
consultant at paper space asia
led by her passion for people-centric
initiatives
angelina's communication skills have
been honed
through her past roles in international
communications
at smrt digital marketing with the cpf
board and as a journalist with singapore
press
holdings now angelina take it away i'll
leave it to you
and please help me welcome all our
panelists and put our hands together
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much valentina for the
lovely introduction
firstly i must say thank you so much for
attending this in person
you have no idea how excited we are to
have a session like this it's been quite
a while since we've been in something
like this
um it is quite a privilege to be on the
stage sharing the stage with andy mark
and sherwin
they are as you can tell by valentina's
introduction they are really quite well
versed in what they do
pandemic has forced organizations to
make really large scale changes and
embrace ways of working that
were previously not quite embraced not
heard of perhaps and
perhaps even shunned so in today's
session what we intend to do is turn the
spotlight onto people the very core of
an organization
most of us of here in the room have the
responsibility to ensure
employees continue to have an enriching
enabling and
empowering experience with their
organization organizations
throughout any types of change and
crisis even
and as winston churchill once said you
never want to waste
a crisis so let's explore how we can
leverage the pandemic to reset or shape
the things that matter additionally i'd
like to highlight
that in this talk we are looking at
defining mobility in two manners
firstly as the physical decentralization
of the workplace
and secondly as what it means to empower
employees to work optimally
from anywhere at any time they choose to
now let me turn it over to the experts
first let's start off this discussion by
talking a little bit about culture at
the work phase
so this is for you mark in your
experience in effective change
within organizations tell us a little
bit about how you would define a time of
change
and what conditions cause change well i
think that's
at this time it's a very easy one to
answer with a pandemic taking place
um but change comes from many different
varieties of from
many different sources um and currently
i think the pandemic is changing
everything whereas change can be
incremental bit by bit i think what
we're seeing right now is
we're in the middle of a transformation
where we were six 12 months ago
where we will be in six to 12 months
will be unrecognizable
many of us think we know where it's
going but i think when we look
when we're in 12 months from now looking
back where we were 12 months ago
it will be a very different world so
it's it's an external force a pandemic
but it can also come from internal
changes
bit by bit a change of ceo a change of
technology
uh stuff like that can can instigate
change
okay and um so on external forces
shelving
i just want to ask you how do you think
the pandemic has shaped
your corporate culture or shifted it
even
i think it's shifted the
the some of the manifestation of it
right but i think if we if we think
about our own corporate culture it's
it's always prided ourselves on
flexibility empowerment
innovation curiosity and collaboration
and a lot of that right
um and actually and we took maybe like
three years ago we started on this
journey from
to move from what would be a traditional
fi fixed deaths and things like that to
be able to
okay we need to break down barriers we
need to have people collaborate more so
we
move from a physical space to our
offices in m1 where
marina won which was much more um nobody
has an office even our c-suite even our
ceo
hair boys open plan high brace uh we
have collaboration areas and things
right
but that whole mindset of being able to
work flexibly and operate
and operate that way allowed us to
actually respond to the pandemic quite
quickly
right because we actually had the
policies in place we have practices we
have the principles in place
we just need to turn on a few more
buttons like maybe vpn licenses
for example um to be able to enable it
so we were able to pivot quite
quickly and if you look at what's
happening industry when
after the circuit breaker and you could
expansion of phases
um for us within the local market we
were
we kept on with our default from home
much longer than many of our players in
the industry right so as long as they
could come back
let's bring as many people back as
possible there was some response
ours was no let's we we learn how to
adapt we learn how to be productive
let's leverage that and see how that
takes us in the future
versus going back right so i think to
answer your question about
culture the representation
of the culture and how we behave now in
our online space virtual
collaboration we we started a journey
before and then that helped us now in a
virtual setting before we move to andy
mark i just want to
check with you does this resonate with
the rest of maybe some of your clients
that you worked with as well
um i think what i'm finding i was taking
a note down as shown was speaking there
and i was thinking more about how
my experience of our culture has changed
over the last
six to twelve months and i think six
twelve months ago i was much more
focused on the local culture
and to some extent that hasn't changed
but what has changed is my exposure and
my integration with our regional and
even global culture
as an organization and i'm much more
aware i'm much more in contact with them
and i feel much more
much closer to them whereas with the
local culture i'm feeling
i wouldn't say more distant it's it's
just a changed relationship with a local
culture because i know how how tall they
are
and i know what they look like in real
life but that global culture i've met
i've not met
i've met very few of them from the
global culture but i feel i know them
quite well because we're interacting so
much more
than we did before so this idea of
distance really has
reduced quite greatly very much so right
yeah okay
um andy you're a strong advocate for
meaningful timely and thorough
employee engagement as part of
strengthening workplace culture
so i'd like to ask you whose
responsibility is it
to engage employees in the process of
strengthening workplace culture
oh wow so um i believe
starting from the culture point of view
i think culture is just one component in
order to get to a high
employee experience over there so i
think there are other components which
have to
fit in together and that's for example
the technology that we are providing our
people out there
and then it's about the physical space
and the physical space
can mean a lot i mean it can be an
office space but nowadays it can be also
then the home office it could be also
remote office places work from anywhere
and so on
so what is important with the part of
employee engagement is
there is actually an input which is
provided by the organization and we call
it commonly
employee experience so the employee
experience is being provided by the
organization
and as a return we are getting engaged
employees right
so that implies already that employee
engagement takes two parties
so it's an employer but it also takes an
employee so it always takes two people
two parties to dance and the challenge
that we often see is um
especially in the singapore environment
that a lot of employees are leaning back
and say
please engage me i'm disengaged at work
can you do something about it
but i always encourage people to say
come on you're an adult human being at
work if you're disengaged
why don't you do the first step and ask
your employer for dance for example
and you come up with some kind of
moonshot ideas in order to increase your
own engagement
so it's really a give and take where it
takes everybody to work together
of course leadership brings the broad
direction over there but the detailed
work um the
employees have the similar
responsibility like the employer
how do you feel about this showing i
think you had a reaction when i first
read out the question yeah so i think um
i think the two angles right so one of
the things that we say
internally is that um with culture that
needs to be a
tone from the top right so this is the
way we're going to be we're going to be
collaborative we're going to trust you
we're going to focus on your output that
you know that's a tone
but then there needs to be an echo from
the bottom right so that it's not just
falling on dry ground like yeah yeah i
i i see that so i i love the construct
that you shared at me around
the partnership right there's two parts
so there's a twofold up and then yes
okay
that's great and i'm going to behave
sorry
technology my watcher is being a critic
but you're right so it's around um
them being able to then behave in this
way right to be able to do it as an echo
and if you don't echo with what the tone
is in
and then maybe that's not the right
culture for you in a way right so that
and that's kind of like what you both
see
right and there might be a different
culture and somewhere else where it's
more suited for you
so i think that's one angle um the
second angle is that i love the concept
of like personal responsibility over
your own engagement
right so i i love the idea of that you
have a
you have an experience of work and that
then gives an output of your engagement
level
right it's an experience that derives
engagement and i do believe that it's
like it's
it's in this world where the needs are
so changing we're being so much more
good
if you're able to highlight your need
and have an idea of how it can be
better engaged with then that's where
that's where the organization can also
like oh that's what you mean okay let's
try to see how we can fit it
so i loved it so that resonates okay
um ma coming back to the idea of
mobility
um would you agree that mobility and
agility thrive in a company that
is based on trust i think it's essential
to have trust for ability
for mobility and agility to function and
they're kind of different aspects of the
same thing
i think if and it's a reciprocal
arrangement between a manager
and and his or her staff um if a manager
trusts their staff to do their work
regardless of where they are whether in
our shop or
or anywhere in the world then uh that
staff should feel empowered to do so but
the reciprocal side is the staff
needs to earn that trust it needs to
show that they've actually
they're actually um worth that trust and
they've earned it
and therefore they can that mutual trust
has to work both ways
and if there's a breach of trust then it
can it can collapse so
absolutely trust is essential for that
process so maybe perhaps in your
personal experience especially because
you feel that
your um reach has almost expanded beyond
just a local
team perhaps you can tell us how you've
nurtured that trust
in your employees i think i think it's
essential to as
a as a manager of people or i'd say a
co-worker with people even if you're a
manager
keep that and keep that hierarchy our
hierarchy as flat as possible
and reach out to your your your
colleagues as often as you can
comfortably do so and be available for
them to reach out to you so if someone
has a quick message on a message
messaging app
you'll be responsive to it and uh you
know
that means that they know that they can
get a quick answer
i think that's becoming so much more
important in this in this kind of
distributed world where we live
um when people can't see somebody and go
i've seen them i need to ask them the
question
they've got to be in mind on the on the
apps and quickly accessible that way
yes i think maybe then um andy can i ask
how do you
reckon what kind of technology or what
kind of platforms perhaps are in
place now that can get you to bridge
that gap
and to provide timely interaction so
in general i mean life is all about
relationships and work is not an
exception right
and can you imagine to build up a
relationship without communicating with
each other it's not possible right so
communication is key
and then of course if now everybody is
geographically dispersed the
communication cannot happen face to face
anymore so we have to
um substitute this something else so now
technology can be the bridge in order to
close those gaps and what is then very
very important that
we have a communication platform where
everybody feels included so that not
someone feels excluded just because they
might not have a corporate email account
which a lot of frontliners actually
don't they never given a corporate email
account
but they all have a smartphone so in our
smartphone we have our common
denominator
where we can now get everyone on the
same platform so now you just need to
have a
proper corporate platform where you can
administer this properly
and then you have an opportunity as a
leader to finally really
communicate openly in a two-way format
with all of your people in an instant at
the same time
so you don't have this telephone game
where the leadership talks to the
managers and the managers talks to the
supervisor supervisor talks to the front
line stuff
and then as a leader you don't really
know what the frontline stuff heard
because it went through certain channels
over there so technology opens up a huge
opportunity over there
to build a trust based communication
in the organization and then it's about
having a proper
cadence so that you set the right
expectation and what kind of intervals
can i expect to hear from the top
leadership and i think that's all
important as well because if you start
to communicate every day suddenly
there's a weak
break then the people say what's wrong
something something happening up there
so i think you have to manage
expectations as well in what kind of
frequency the senior leadership is for
example
using a certain platform but i think if
i can if i can jump in there i think
the challenge with a lot of the
technology is people are booking
time to sort of like get that uh that
meeting together
and someone says can i have a quick chat
with you and then you say yeah check my
calendar and
the next gap is in in seven days time
yeah that
that that connection keeps evaporating
and so somehow we as
people manager staff whatever need to
find a way
to be connecting with each other more in
a more casual way
as though we might have done had we
bumped into each other in the office and
that i think is something
that some of us are learning it i think
i'm learning how to do it
some of us are still trying to figure it
out and others are
way way behind the curve um i think
maybe shelvin i would like to ask how do
you because you're a very busy man you
have back-to-back meetings you take
calls and cars and
you take calls whenever you can i don't
know how would you make time
for your employees should they need to
speak to you yes sir okay
so i think um the reality is that the
calendar
is yours and you have to control it
right so i i
what marks this resonates to be able to
be able to provide blocks in your
schedule that you are able to take that
you may be able to unlock
for the for stuff that comes up right
you will slack into your
the system so to speak um but i also
take a
it sounds formal but it depends how it's
executed right
so i do have um weekly catch-ups before
my direct reports i have about to catch
up with the ones that are below that
um we do have a team engagement team
stuff and and those might sound very
formal because it's scheduled but in its
execution you can make it casual or
informal right so every meeting that we
have
we have an emotional check-in right so
to check in to have people hear how
you're experiencing today what are you
feeling
um anything that's distracting you what
you need to be so like you are actually
checking in onto the plane you're fully
here
right we give building time for the the
human connection
and actually it's a lot of we talked
about um i think both of us talked about
leadership by example setting the tone
so i'm very
authentic with my own um um
let's say personal life we say personal
life but the reality is that
i think that we have one life with many
aspects
right and sometimes at work we tend to
only show the work aspect
right but i think if you say that
actually it's okay to talk about
stressors that you have today
and yeah and you might not be the best
uh position today because you're a bit
frenzied because my kids had a meltdown
this morning and
they'll you know i get it and then and
it's very real and people experience it
right and you have the people at home
and suddenly your kid pops out on screen
or something happens the dog comes so
you have to pause my grab you know
that's all bunch of interruptions
but it's also very human and if you
present yourself as being that human
i think it sets the tone and provides
kind of like the tone for psychological
safety for people to be themselves
and it comes with for me it comes with a
belief that if
people are allowed to be their authentic
selves
that's where you get diversity of
thought that's where you get that
thinking and that's where you get
innovation
more empathy and you have better
outcomes right so it's all connected
you know it's not just a few good
factors so i think best for me on a
personal front
i would like to add on to this one i
think nowadays we have to be very very
proactive on managing our communication
because who is not feeling
somehow burned out from back to back
soon meetings all the time and then
maybe five minutes out of the 45 minutes
were really relevant over there
so what um some of our clients are doing
is that um they're actually having
meetings where the people can
participate is not compulsory
and then someone is a big organization
so someone takes in the effort
to condense this kind of meeting into
five minutes
and then they're uploading a video on
the platform over there
so it becomes asynchronous communication
so people can watch this
at their own time so you give back
autonomy to the people and say okay you
control what kind of information you
take in
it's all available for you over here
those are the condensed meeting minutes
and and you can then take it in
in a format that is nice to digest and
easy to digest over there
but especially what you refer to this
human to human connections have to be
real time
yeah because um they happen so often in
the office
this is water cooler talks where you
bump into people by accident
and it's not happening anymore now in
the virtual world so sometimes we have
to recreate this kind of forums
where people can just happen to meet
each other by accident and talk about
anything under the sun right so there's
literally no agenda over there and then
you just see how the dynamic in that
group
develops because um what what i am
worried about is that over time with
this kind of
remote work we are losing um innovations
because um i don't get ideas when i'm
staring at the computer screen
by myself i get ideas when i talk to
people from different domains from
different departments
around the pantry or the coffee talk and
so on
and this is not happening then i i do
fear that we are losing innovative speed
in organizations okay um let's shift
gears a little bit and speak a little
bit more about hybrid work
and flexibility so showing this one is
for you actually
um especially because i think prudential
has always been all about flexible
flexibility
so um a question here would be why does
flexibility matter
to employees why should organizations
provide the support
to help with this yeah so okay so if
you're asking why
what would help the corporate thinking
that this is needed right maybe i'll
share our own thinking
so if you think about hybrid work and
it's it's how do we
flexibly meet the needs better right and
when we say needs maybe there's three
broad categories right
so there's the business needs like
things need to happen deliveries need to
do
and stuff like that and in what manner
in what is the manner of work or
modality of work
that needs to accomplish that goal right
so if if you're
standalone if you're just doing focus
work frankly you could do that from
anywhere
right but sometimes there's a
collaboration piece there's value in
coming into room drawing on the board
and things so there's that to be done
in person so that's why it's a hybrid
right some things happen in the office
something happens remotely
but if you look at also what i think is
quite important is that we look at
customers needs right
so if you think about about it things
are changing a lot
but the need for us to serve our
customers these hasn't changed
what has changed is the customer's needs
are rapidly evolving
right and now then the question is how
do we
how do we be more flexibly able
to meet your customers needs right from
a different timing from things i mean
even if you look at call centers you
used to be a certain time how could now
now people are really used to having a
11 12 in the old day i'm from insurance
right
like how many and when it used to be
insurance program
how many of you will be able to see your
agent in your home at 11 pm at night
right very rare but during the pandemic
having a 11
a zoom call is common right so suddenly
that
that change actually sometimes for you
for the clients
that's the only time they have after
their back-to-back calls but it's an
important thing they want to cover their
children that's the only slot
and you have to be able to make it
available right so that whole move from
in person to virtual right so that's a
flexible
and sorry how's that i mean it's just
the whole assumptions that we're making
nowadays about
where a meeting takes place it has
changed radically
um i i'm going to refer to my wife who
had an appointment with the doctor
and she turned up at the doctor it was
for a kind of a consultation
and that the doctor wasn't there and
they'd assumed that it was going to be a
virtual appointment
and she was like no i'm paying enough
money for this appointment i wanted to
be in person
and then and then by contrast today i
was on the meeting with my colleagues in
china in shanghai
and they all assumed it was in person
and it's like where's the dial in i
can't dial in it's like oh
okay oh right yeah we'll set one up so
assumptions are changing radically as to
where uh
where where meetings take place and how
hybrid working happens
so i think hybrid working is not about
the individual doing hybrid working
i think it's about the collective the
group the team doing hybrid working
whether it's your customers and your and
your vendors whether it's your team
you're not one person working hard but
that's what doesn't matter
it's it's how do you interact with your
colleagues and where are they i love
what mark's saying because
i saw about three right so business
these customers needs and of course the
premise of a question was employee needs
right
and i think um the reality is that
different people have different needs
right so that we we do and we do have to
recognize that there are some people
whose home environment is not conducive
for work
right so there's and you have to provide
an office space for them right in some
people's their home environment
actually requires them to be more at
home than ever in any office right and
there's a flexibility there
and and i have to say i i love which
home
yeah their home their
the other thing is the um
um i think the mental wellness right the
psychological wellness and being
unfriend right even like what mark is
saying like
i don't know what's going on what should
i be doing like this
need to be able to shadow stuff is an
additional mental load on people
actually right and if we look at uh
mental wellness uh um
and he said that we lose the we lose the
innovation right the conversation that
sparked innovation when we don't see
people in person
but the other thing is also the social
connection and the mental wellness
and the the psychological wellness that
comes from their social connection right
i know i know i remember when we first
came up i have colleagues who actually
they realize like
your friends at work were people that
you might unload or van
or stuff with your problems at home
right but then when you don't go to home
you only have the problems at home
you know so so that that that friends
that work element
and actually experiencing that
friendship as a real relationship
is actually really key yeah um so our
position within prudential is that
actually
you should spend two days of the week
the recommendation is two days of the
week
with your teams in person but we give a
framework we give a thing and we don't
have all the answers so we're saying
that this is it we came up with a
playbook
and we said okay everybody please use
this framework to have the conversations
in your team
to decide what's good for your team
right
and as what mark said we don't know
right so after all let's tweak let's
have conversations let's be able to see
and then we form as and the policy has
to be that level of principle
to allow that flexibility as we tweak
along right so
i think it's important part because
otherwise you lose social capital
yeah if you don't prepare this it
doesn't happen by itself it has to be a
little bit instigated by the
organization over there
but if i may i would like to to take
another perspective on this one because
we talk a lot about
hybrid work work from anywhere and so on
and we have to be more conscious and
aware that we're actually talking about
a minority of the global workforce
who even has the privilege of working
from anywhere
because the vast majority of the global
workforce 60 to 80 percent
they can only dream of this privilege of
working from home
because they're in logistics and
hospitality they're in health care
they're in manufacturing and so on they
have to be where their work is
and we must not forget about them when
we talk about the future of work and
then only talk about the office workers
but we are not improving
the work life harmony of our frontliners
out there our essential workers or
i like to call them the high social
value workers
which luckily enough now with all this
pandemic we appreciate them more than
we did in the past and we have to keep
up this momentum and really do something
about their employee experience as well
okay that's very insightful we must not
forget those people so the high value
people
high social value excuse me okay um
let's move on to managing change um mark
again why are you taking on me he's an
expert he's the expert at this though
could you perhaps share with
us the biggest reasons that fuel and
drive
positive change in an organization sorry
the biggest
reason the biggest reasons and the
biggest contributors
that can drive positive change in an
organization
i wasn't prepared for that one can i
pass it i like to ask some questions
that you are not prepared for right
well the biggest reasons to drive
positive change are in order to realize
change if you don't drive positive
change
you're not going to get change happening
you're going to get resistance people
are going to go
whoa why why is this you know if people
are up in arms against it they're not
going to they're not gonna
embrace the change at all and so you
have to drive positive change now how to
do that
i think is is through has to be through
engagement you have to bring the people
on the journey
um you can't assume that they're going
to be in favor of it neither can you
assume they're going to be against
it you can assume that they don't know
what's going on and they need to be
informed so
you need to bring them on on a journey
of understanding why is this change
happening
how is it going to affect you personally
individually how is it going to affect
your team
and why is it good for the organization
to understand what's going on and that
gradually will get acceptance and once
they've got acceptance you're kind of
halfway there to the buy-in piece
if they're accepting that the change has
to happen um whether they like it or not
they
may still not buy into it but you have
to go through a process of
get that kind of uh education i hate
that word actually it's it's kind of
engagement communication touchy feely
whatever
it's all of that stuff uh if you want to
get make a successful change happen okay
what about this
idea of ownership we would like to try
and propagate some sort of ownership
throughout the company when it comes to
change or any sort of change that you
want to see with our company right
how do you think you would nurture this
ownership idea of
ownership so what i like to uh
when i think about this i think you've
got the leadership of an organization
are planning a change because it's the
right thing for the organization to do
one has to assume
that that's a given the right thing for
the organization at the top may not
necessarily be the right thing for the
organization at the bottom
and sometimes the guys at the coalface
in the trenches on the front line
see things that the guys at the top
level don't see and
they want to wave a flag and go guys
guys guys this is going to kill
our business pay you know pay attention
and maybe they're right
maybe they're they're they're they're
seeing something the leadership have not
seen
so creating a feedback loop is extremely
important
the leadership at the same time have to
recognize that there's a feedback loop
that the people at the front line
are qualified decent professional people
who take their job seriously not
ignoramuses who are just trying to make
noise and be resistant
and so they have to listen so yeah so as
a change agent a change manager
you need to build that communications
loop um and that will
that will breed engagement and that will
give the people on the front line a
chance to be heard
it may well be that the leadership say
yeah we've actually thought of that one
and there's a big picture here which you
don't appreciate so thank you for the
feedback
but we're still going to do it this way
then at least the people who are kind of
flagging things up
feel like they're heard and that they're
being taken seriously
not disregarded that's an extremely
important point what we don't want the
leadership to do
is to go yeah yeah thanks ignore them
we've kind of yeah yeah we heard you
carry on because that will
disengage people and they'll lose
ownership okay sharing the question for
you
um in effecting change effecting change
you would need the help from not just
your top leaders
you would also need to manage a middle
management as well and i'm sure you
have had ways to equip them with the
skills needed to drive
forward change
[Laughter]
so would you care to share some some
ways that has been done in prudential
okay so so i think in corporate language
we use
drive change right you drive change but
maybe the the the premise this is maybe
more personal right
so the premise um that i think i think
we influence
rather than drive or cause right because
it's about people and
how do we influence people and and and
the specific framework i
i personally like and i use around that
is that is the influence model which
means that
for the premises for anybody to be able
to
say okay i choose to change my mindset
and my behavior that's what you're after
right
but to be able for them to say that they
have to say four things first right
um i know why i have to change i know
what's being asked of me and i know why
right i can see other people behaving in
this new way
and having this i have the skills to
behave in this new way
and barriers are being removed
or i'm being rewarded to move in this
new way right
and if you and you list that from an
activity perspective you
have to be able to like foster
understanding you have to kill role
models
there's a skills capability and you have
reinforcement mechanisms
if you think about these four questions
and you look at the us as individuals
the change processes that we have gone
through quite often the company is
pretty good at one or two
right i'm pretty good at telling the
story this is why right almost everybody
gets there
right but are you really great at
promoting the role models
that's not just at the leadership level
but they are at their managers and then
their peers
because some people might be early
adopters that are more more moving right
so like hey look this is what is
happening and this is great
sometimes it's like oh wow that's a
great idea
but what do i do now i don't know how to
do that like he's so great but i don't
know how to do that
so that whole skills piece right of
being able to let i want you to work
remotely that means there's this thing
there's these things right and
and the enablement is really is really
key
um um because and the reinforcement
mechanisms is that both that
it's so difficult to remove in this way
but sherwin you're saying this
but the systems are so painful right
i see i see a lot of laughter in the
room actually right so that resonates
right
so that how do we remove those specific
barriers and how do we reward them right
so for us
in our culture peace and values we want
to bring our values to life we are
translating to actual behaviors
they want the whole organization to
behave in a certain way right so we have
a form to
shift we we educate them we'll be able
to do it and then to be able to then say
everybody please behave in this
particular way and this great person is
being this way hey your
your friend is behaving this way you
have the skills
and actually we're going to measure that
this is happening and we are going to be
rewarded as a team
around it right so so that's sort of
like that
and that four questions needs to be
answered
in the context of every level of the
organization
and your managers to the original
question of like the managers
need to be able to then help their staff
or their team answer those as well this
is what's
to to mark's point of what's it meant
for you right this is why you need to
change
but this is how you can do it and let's
all move together okay
taking the perspective of employees andy
how do you think
employees employees can be empowered to
participate in change
and how can they be ensured that they're
being heard
so i like this four questions that um
sherman was
sharing there because it's it shows
respect and i think respect
respect lack of respect is a big
obstacle to change
but giving the people respect inviting
everyone to become part of the change i
mean we have this
human inertia for change right why
because um we know the status quo
there's certain
certainty but when there's a change as
uncertainty and as humans we don't
really like uncertainty over there
but um we also don't like to be changed
but a lot of us don't mind to become
part of the change if we get invited
um to become part of the change and i i
echo what
what mark also shared over there i i
think we have to respect our frontliners
who are serving our customers
that they often might know better what
the customers like or don't like
uh compared to the guys sitting there in
the ivory tower who haven't seen a
customer for
for donkey years so we have to invite
our
experts our front liners our loyal
long-serving
employees into the change process by
giving them an opportunity a platform
where they can voice their opinions
and some of our clients have used it
very intelligently for example that they
have an
innovation drive months where everybody
can share some innovative ideas from the
front lines
and then the whole piece the whole
community is voting on those ideas
and then the leadership is just
observing what's happened there so you
have your your swarm intelligence
working and then after the one month you
see which ideas got the most
upwards from the peers and that might be
the ones which work best
because the whole swarm intelligence
decided this over there
and then um when the leadership picks up
these ideas and it's visible in this
social platform over there
you win a lot of respect with your
people because you don't say i'm the
clever guy up there i know what works
and what doesn't work no
i mean invite the people and let the
democracy democracy inside
decide over there what we should go
forward
so that's an opportunity which some
companies are embracing
okay um so this idea on
what you mentioned a little bit about uh
ideas new ideas that are coming out
um shelving for you again in
implementing change and testing new
ideas
um what's what's the sweet spot in
implementing it
or waiting for data to confirm that this
is one way or to go
oh wow because i asked this because i
know prudential was very
quick to implement ideas yes i want to
understand
what what unlike some other children
maybe unlike other companies that wait
for some sort of
clear indication that this will work
before they implement it
you're ready to go ahead okay so so i
think
firstly the sweet spot is quite
situational
depending on the situation depending on
stuff the sweet spot might shift right
but maybe since we were talking about
hybrid working i use that example right
so um there was a lot of debate
internally
when okay we can come back to the office
should it be two days should we three
days should we mandate three business
days
and there's a variety of conversations
around that and then
and my usual note is to be able to
engage and ask the business
what do they need and stuff like that
but the reality is
nobody really knows because it's new
right so i realized after a number of
discussion is a whole bunch of
hypothesis
which may or may not be true right so in
the end we said okay
let's the so that the approach we're
taking is that let's
anchor people in some level of uh
understanding
a common language language say so this
is the reasons uh pros and cons of
working from home with things and all
this is and that's enabled so there's a
playbook
right so that people are educated on the
things but then
let's try we have a we have a hypothesis
two days in the office
um or two days face to face rather maybe
maybe not in the office
um and then let's try and we listen and
we pivot and stuff
if i listen if i waited for data for
everybody
the reality is you go online and you can
and you can hear
leading lights of the industry on both
ends
right but what is unique for us we have
to actually experience it
have an hypothesis test right we have
this hypothesis let's try and then we
can be able to do that so
so so that will be example a specific
example of the hybrid work
approach right but but you have a
variety of thoughts there are some
people that you have to have a
very tight frame okay the principle is
that we we give
autonomy and empowerment within a frame
the discussion is how how tight should
that frame be
right and the reality is you have to try
and you have to try and find out
and the danger is when somebody goes
like i know this will work
and i'm like okay you have a hypothesis
interesting enough i know angelina
you've got a bit of a bug bear about
design thinking
but what you've just described is
exactly design thinking it's an
iterative process
we've got a hypothesis let's prototype
it let's roll it out and let's use that
as a tool for for
for change and see if that works and
iterate from that so
i just sidestep there because i know
it's been floating around in the
background
that is what we want to get to yeah so
we caught on there
okay um looks like we're almost out of
time for the panel discussion
um i think i just have maybe one
question
for all three of you uh what are the
three most
important factors to you in reframing a
crisis
to opportunities for change wow
is that a really big question um let
andrea stop
sorry
and that wasn't you don't have to jump
into that
so you you were asking what are the
three factors to convert a crisis into
an opportunity
how would you invest in that yeah i
believe
um change is not not painful resistance
to changes is painful
so so we all have to embrace it and i
think if you look back we have been
changing all the time and we can just
take an
um crisis like this one as a nice
catalyst in order to
to create some changes which in the past
maybe we had ideas but it didn't really
happen
like what we have seen with some of our
clients they were sitting on the fence
for the longest time
regarding digital transformation but now
with this crisis suddenly
they can't run away from it anymore they
have to
make work possible and suddenly they
jump on this digital train and they
realize
it's not so difficult after all you take
one step even a small step is a step
forward and then you can
embrace this little baby steps
okay even baby steps or progress shall
we
um i think is the lens
of i think um
[Music]
the needs of customers employees and the
organizational setup
right so why i say this i think that
when it comes to crisis we must
really be very clear to recognize
what is changing but what also stays the
same
right so i give you example from hr
function right so what if
everybody says everything is changing
but actually what stays the same is that
we
create value for our customers our
distributors our investors and employees
that has not changed right what has
changed is the needs of those people
has changed and how they respond to that
better how do we do people to that and
when you have the needs mindset
that always brings to with what you're
saying right the
opportunities to better meet the needs
of all these sectors
better than another organization
right and then that's where the
opportunity comes so that's sort of
my interpretation yeah um apologies by
the way
wow what a question um i think the
way to approach any crisis to say okay
um what's the worst that could happen
and let's let's break it down into each
each category what's the worst that can
happen
and how can we turn that into a win
what would it be so if everybody has to
work from home is it
really that bad is is there any positive
is there a
silver lining in that one or if they're
going to be healthy
health health and well-being challenges
they're going to crop up because
people are stuck indoors for months on
end
what can we do to turn that into a
delight find the delight in that
somewhere and how can we kind of turn it
on its head
so i think bit by bit you do that and
what you could i mean what we do
what we are doing a lot is checking with
the people and saying
what you know what's it like for you
tell me what's bad and tell me you tell
me
what would make it not so bad for you
tell me what to make it great for you
and again back to listening to your
people listening to your customers
listening to what's going on in their
heads
and saying well what can we do to help
and sometimes just that
active listening can can really help
people open up
because the worst piece is that they've
got no way to open up and they've got
that they're bottling up
they're bottling up the issues inside
and saying who do i turn to
like you don't need to join anybody
we're here we're opening the door for
you
okay thank you very much for your time
now we shall turn
um i'll hand it over to valentina to
take us through the q
a portion i hope all of you have many
many questions ready
i can see everybody so enthusiastic
everyone who's online please feel free
to use the q a module
on your webinar but as for us here
anybody has any questions please raise
your hand and we will pass you
the microphone
okay maybe we can start in one of the
online questions
the first is uh to sherwin actually
since embracing new workflows and
arrangements has there also been a shift
in how your organization measures the
success and performance of its people
what are some of these changes in
approach um
that's a great question right and you
know from the influencing
model that i talked about the fourth one
is removing barriers and rewarding for
new positions right
so i think our advantage was because we
started this journey a few years
earlier so so when i so for example
already our performance matrix or matrix
encompasses a very big component on the
how we are doing things
right and how we are bringing the vet
and when we say how we're doing things
is
how we're bringing the values to life
right how are we being ambitious how
we've been curious
are you creating your own learning
journey are you being nimble
are we testing new ideas are we being
empathetic to our people
right so that level of things is
actually something that we are
creating we're purporting we are
perpetuating we are saying propagating
if you will
and it's then being measured through a
feedback channel
of your things to be able to tell and
we're building a feedback culture as
well
and the mechanism then rolls up into
um actually your performance appraiser
at the end of the year
right so it's really important it's 360s
from it's from all over the place
and that's quite key um we started the
journey
uh a little bit before the pandemic and
if this benevolent reinforces that so
much
right to be able that that it's much
more outcome oriented because your
what's a very clear
objectives versus being here and every
day
but also how are those being measured
right so that's there will be one thing
that's been shifted
um yeah andy would you like to
add to that i think earlier we had a bit
of a discussion and how
yeah you were talking about uh employee
metrics
of course there's an organization you
would also see whether you're making any
progress
and and in in the end
it's about business results right and
the the lucky thing is that there's a
lot of research out there that really
employ engagement is one of the
leading indicators for business results
i mean we don't want to just look at an
isolated employee engagement score
that's not really very meaningful
it's about um are we getting better than
yesterday
so it's about measuring this on a
continuous basis over there
because when the employee engagement
score is trending upwards
over time you can expect a few quarters
afterwards better business results
because simply the people are more
engaged at work
and the opposite is also true if your
employee engagement score is dropping
then you you must be prepared for worse
business results in the end
so it's a beautiful leading indicator
that we have in our arsenal of kpis
unfortunately we are not measuring it as
frequently as for example our monthly p
l i mean you nobody can imagine to run a
company with
p l which comes out once a year right
but for employee engagement often we do
that we only measure it once a year
and then we are wondering why we are not
really making a dent and
not really improving over there yeah
simply not enough data points in order
to do anything meaningful with that
that's a really good point i didn't
think of it that way at all andy thank
you
um mark would you like to ask sure i
mean i think i think with the
um employee engagement scores as you
said it's kind of once a year
you're not really you haven't really got
your finger on the pulse of the of the
of the team or the individual you may
have your finger on the pulse of the
organization which beats once per year
which doesn't sound like it's alive i
think it's really up to managers to
manage their teams
on a regular basis and we what we need
to get higher employee engagement scores
is to have better managers managing
their people in a more
interactive more personable way and for
that we need to train managers
yes anybody from the audience
yes
hello hi um
so what's your opinion question for
anyone
what's your opinion on the effects of
hybrid working or working from home
on employees sort of connection to the
brand
of the larger organization and
um if you think that that is the case
um what can companies do to get around
that
would you like yeah yeah i can um that's
great sorry your name was
that's nice to meet you this is a lovely
question right so i think
we have to move from culture being
physical um experiences
versus actual relationship and work
experience
right so if you think about the brand
sorry example i i work for potential
it's great i um and we embrace hybrid
and flexibility all the time i had
a team call the other day while i was
having acupuncture treatment so i'm
i'm because i have needles sticking out
of me and um
i think there's something poetic in
there um but uh and i was on a call
right
and i'm able to building thing and being
able to build health
wellness and stuff and that whole
experience when i will call we are
always focused on are we running
inclusive meetings
that support our uh our ambition that
when we end the call we are saying like
what's the take away from this call and
everybody shares and stuff which is kind
of like our
curious value bringing to life right so
there's a number of things like this
which i wouldn't be experiencing in
another organization
i wouldn't be able to do it and then and
to and this point
before we started was that culture
is a really differentiating factor for
companies right
so if you're able to ensure that even
the remote experience
and the hybrid experience is unique to
you
and it's being able to better meet your
employees needs and yet have a
commonality theme right so we do
these emotional check-ins we dance
what's your learning what you're saying
what do we do why we do a pre-mortem you
know there's a number of things that we
do which might not be so
usual um and then that's kind of like
how you be like oh this is what it means
for me to be
for the employee this is what it means
for me to be working for an organization
in this
time that takes care of my needs right
um
so that that's a and you have to find it
for yourself because
all employee populations are different
right for different contexts or
different things and certain things
might work
differently right so that would be my
response okay any other questions in the
fall
oh yes maybe i would like to take a shot
at this as well
of course please because you're putting
really the finger in the wound and and i
also see a lot of downside to all this
kind of
work from anywhere and nobody's coming
back to the office
because in the end we also touch on it
we are losing social capital there and a
lot of companies
are differentiating themselves because
of a strong social capital
and as an individual i mean what are we
all striving for in the end it's a sense
of belonging right
so if i'm suddenly now isolated working
there alone i might be okay with this as
an introvert for a while
but then for the extrovert i think it
was excruciating pay in the last 12
months to just work by themselves
and then of course over time it's a
challenge for your organization to rope
that back in
because you have to look also in the
long run um
there might be then this effect only
people who come back to the office are
visible to the bosses and then they get
promoted faster than others the quiet
ones over there
so you the company has to proactively do
something in order
to level the playing field again for for
the people who are not coming to the
office
often so it's a lot of effort in order
to avoid this that people lose
psychological safety that they feel
emotionally disconnected from the
organization
it's not easy so i'd like to sort of
build up on that as well because i think
it goes back to the behaviors the
the corporate culture is to some extent
defined by the ceo and the management
the leadership
and it kind of cascades down and to
sherwin's point made
somewhat earlier if there's an echo that
comes back from the people in the
organization
and i think what builds up the cult the
concept of the organizational culture is
that
the song from on high from the
leadership and the echo that comes back
from from the staff
and if you want to have a good song if
you want to sing in harmony it's back to
that those managers
those leaders they need to be trained
they need to know how
how the effect that they have by saying
the wrong thing or by not reaching out
or but not communicating
what's the effect or what's the effect
they're not having on their corporate
culture
so there's one can talk a lot about the
physical workplace and the the brand the
decoration the colors
the fabrics and all that stuff it plays
a part it gives it a tangible quality
yeah but culture is fundamentally less
tangible and it comes through those
behaviors and through this through the
through the leadership i think
yeah um i'll add uh two things we'll
come to your question in a while
um but i think um there is that
individual basis and you remember what i
shared
in a hybrid working approach we
actually have a position that we need to
be able to engage
twice a week face to face right to for
specifically for that issue right
because you
lose connection with people you lose
friends and things right so that's one
um two i think i i really like mark's
point because
the i think managers the call to
managers
have really up in to be able to be very
inclusive
in your style in your practice in your
leadership right
so the so the the the antidote to
uh being distance right is to be
inclusive
and when we say inclusive and that's
very inclusive and belonging there's a
massive piece and you mentioned
belonging
the piece is that um you want to be as
inclusive
as possible for all the biases that you
might have
right and what's popular in the market
is gender biases and all these biases
which are very true
but with remote working and hybrid
working actually there's a bias we need
to be really conscious of which is
distance bias
right i tend to think more people who
are near to me
versus people who are far away from me
how many of you have been in a hybrid
call
where there's some people in the room
and some people are online and
the conversation is dominated by the
people in the room right
so actually the chair of the meeting and
the lisa meeting needs to understand
that there are some people who have a
distance bias is natural and you might
apply to that
and how do we be inclusive of that to be
able to take more attention
what do you guys think what do you have
things and to not just have a side chat
or we were just talking about you know
you have to
have those behaviors do you think so i i
highly i
recommend i highly echoed that if that
uh
answered your question fantastic
can we have your question done
hi guys um i wanted to talk about the
there's a lot of information about
always spoken about
mental health but what about the
physical health
how do you ensure that employees are
taking care of themselves
when they are at home and not say
sitting on the couch doing the laptop
like i mean it's comfortable but
maybe in six months to a year time it
might not work out so how do you ensure
that
employees are keeping healthy in that
regards
you guys well i have a response but what
did you guys get that is your domain
physical workplace yes i suppose i
suppose it is in my domain
um i mean let me let me put a slightly
different spin on that
so how do how does one assure that even
in a non-hybrid workplace
when you get people coming to the office
if they choose to sit on a chair when
they have a choice of an ergonomic chair
let's talk about use that simple example
their ergonomic chair
um how can we encourage them to sit
there and not to sit on a seat that
looks like this one
which is very uncomfortable by the way
after an hour and a half here
i need to stand up and move um we can't
do that it's really there's at some
point
again you have to get people to learn to
be um
to take responsibility for themselves
but you're one of your four points of
enabling people to do it is you've got
to remove the barriers so if the barrier
is that well i haven't i
haven't got an ergonomic seat at home or
i can't afford it or whatever
then is there a channel there to take
that that particular element of the
christ and turn it upside down so it's
an opportunity
for us to give you or provide for you or
some other way
give you an ergonomic workstation if
it's about physical exercise getting up
and exercising
nobody's going to get me to do that
i i read about one example from a
company in the us whether
basically it started and then everybody
had at the zoom session over there
and as icebreakers and they said please
show us
show us your home so they were
encouraged to walk with a laptop around
and show their home
and then there was a very observant
manager and then he observed what is the
environment over there and he looked oh
they're sitting in the kitchen table
they have just a normal wooden chair
over
there and then he really sent them
a check and said yeah 200 buy yourself
some some ergonomic chair
yeah so there's a very nice human touch
it was
certainly not expected by the people
doesn't cost the company a lot of things
but it makes a huge difference to the
employee if they get
appreciated in that way it's also
similar that their culture to the
earlier point if the
showing the organization cares uh yeah
so i'm not sure if i have answers but i
can share what we what are we trying to
do
okay so i think in the world of like
making sure that they have a proper
setup
um in the beginning one of our big
responses was okay
everybody has to work from home not
everybody has equipment how do we send
them monitors chairs
that we will be in the office to their
homes to be able to have a big screen
and to have a
at least at least as ergonomic as you
would have been in the office right so
that's
from organic space i think in terms of
our let's say our sports and rec club
src when we pivoted you know we were
it was called dos con orange for those
of you remember so we
we had a project orange so like how do
we help
people have um some sort of level of
things so we had
um yoga online virtual classes and all
that sort of stuff we introduced
meditation online
which was actually pretty uh popular and
had more engagement that we have so
that's from
like a company providing type
perspective
even eap is changing right so if you
think about the employee assistance
program
of companies quite often they are like
the in-house company
um um emergency hotline
right but we're actually shifting that
we're shifting that instead of just like
when you're in trouble when you're in
mental
distress call this number how do we keep
you out of being in mental distress
right so now we have
change we are changing our eap to be
able to have offer life coaching i have
to be able to progress how they have to
have wellness we have a app that has
meditation and
stuff and all that sort of thing right
so that's the mental wellness bit
um from the physical health then it has
to be a conversation expectation
right so we are we we're an insurance
company where we say i have our purpose
is to have people get the most out of
life
so actually our um credential pulse app
you can check your age
or you can take your photo and it will
tell you like how old you are as for
your photo
chronograph age you have your web doctor
you have things but there's this whole
theme of being able to engage around
what your health means what
package means and be able to do that you
know when circuit breaker hit
i had there was not much to do so i
still practice actually i lost 24 kilos
i'm sorry it's a lot bigger than um and
then after that i put on 12. so the
whole year i was net 12 down
and then this year i've lost seven right
but um
i think that whole rhythm to be able to
balance uh things and what happened
what happened for me personally and i
encourage my whole team to do it
is to start to have walking meetings
because if you remember circuit breaker
the only time you could go
out is for groceries or for walk right
so then what i would do is that i would
share you calls that i didn't need the
screen with
to have a walk and actually it was funny
because my goal was like five k's
and then after i finished five k's the
call hadn't ended yet
so i just continued walking to the court
ends and then they got me into a thing
and so so you have to
find the rhythm for your health and
wellness to be able to do it
but i i highly believe in what life how
many you mentioned about life
integration
right how do you it's not mutually
exclusive how what are the opportunities
where you could live reach each other
for that right so and then you have team
walking meetings even though everybody's
on the quality walking and
and things like that right so so i would
encourage people to be
flexible and to think out of the box for
the base need
i think i think there's um i think
organizations do have a responsibility
to their their people
uh when they are working in a hybrid way
especially if i mean we're seeing so
many organizations
cutting their footprint and therefore
cutting their rent their operating costs
saving enormous amounts of money by by
allowing or engaging or permitting or
facilitating
hybrid work what i'm i'm seeing
something of but maybe not enough of is
how
those organizations are now helping
their people to
get a good home office set up and we
recognize that some people don't have
the space or they don't have the
circumstances to do that
but um i i would quite like to see uh
organizations increasingly have an
ergonomist who would
make themselves available to visit
people at home and come up with a menu
of ideas
that they could do either from
improvising stuff at home which might be
as simple as
stacking some some books up on a table
so you can have a standing
uh workstation very cheap and simple or
you know take it up to various levels of
degree
and to comment on the health the adverse
health impacts
of working in the way that they
currently are on a day-to-day basis
of course there are questions of privacy
and intrusiveness and all that so it's
got to be elective but
i'd like to see more of that happening
okay
we actually have a question uh online um
and this is to mark how do you handle a
team who is resistant to change do
well it's it's kind of uh tell them tell
them tell them again
it's why why is it and it is a bit of
you know if there is
um okay we'll start with why is the
change actually happening and
that is the fundamental reason the why
has to be communicated
it has to be communicated from absolute
top in order to get back to that
cycle of understanding acceptance and
then ultimately buy-in and you don't
necessarily get to buy in
until very very late in the stage when
people actually see it
trust me it'll be fine it's not going to
get you buying
they have to see it to believe it so it
is it is it is
very strong communication from the top
very strong behavioral demonstration of
what's how it's going to work how we are
also we the leadership
top down are also affected so you can't
expect
people the leadership to expect their
staff to change without themselves they
themselves demonstrating
that they are also affected by the
change and embracing it
whether they like it or not because it's
the the for the greater good of the
organization
and we're talking about organizational
change here so that's being done
for the purpose of the organization for
its commercial success it's it's not a
democracy it's a it's a commercial
proposition
ultimately communicate engage you're
never going to get 100
buy-in you're going to try and shift the
double negatives into the sort of
negative zone and the negatives into the
slightly positive zone and the positives
great if you can push them over to the
double positive zone
if you are engaging with the staff and
back to that point the people on the
front line if they're resisting it
why are they resisting it yeah is there
is there a strong reason
and sometimes if it's personal and
selfish as well because i don't want to
change you know that that can happen
but if it's again treating people as
adults mature professionals
then listen to them and they may be
saying this is not just in my own
interest yes it is as well
but it's also in in the commercial
interest as well i've actually got my
professional interests
as part of this organization at heart so
it's it's listening
it's communicating and it's dialogue i
think that's how i tackle it i think
that's very well answered
um would anybody else like to add to
that um
example from from what our clients have
been doing on our platform then
um when they had some change of course
it's not everyone
like a big wave right it starts with
some trickle and then leadership really
looked for
examples where employees embraced the
change
and then made a small story out of this
one and shared this story on this social
media platform in-house
so that people kept could visualize it a
little bit more what does it mean
and the people who change should be on
the peer-to-peer level right so it's not
their boss and say i change and he'll
show you how it is
now it should be someone on the
peer-to-peer level where the others can
relate to
and then if you visualize it even maybe
a small video clip
a few photos inside make it make it
approachable make it social over there
so a lot of people realize oh that's
that's what you mean by service with a
change
because sometimes when you just verbally
explain it people cannot picture it
properly
so we have to take advantage of all the
media that we have over there in order
to make it a little bit more
approachable for for the people
okay um do we have another question from
the floor
okay oh yes over there
hi everyone suman here from prudential
uh so my question is to
mark or anyone else who would like to
answer
so with organizations at this point it's
a bit easier when you talk about real
estate and giving up space
uh because it's a huge cost savings so
they are supportive of the change
uh we don't know where we would be in 6
months right should there be a case
whereby this doesn't work
for the organization it doesn't suit the
organization culture
and people have given up space how then
does the workplace evolve and what does
that mean in terms of culture
and the resistance from the organization
itself
uh to go back to taking on additional
space
uh that's a that's
a that's a really good question so we're
i've been talking to a number of
organizations around
the region about this exact same
question um
so there's there's a couple of answers
to that it's not it's not a clear-cut
answer because we're still
we don't know what the future looks like
yet um
on the one hand there's a very pragmatic
what's the physical workplace strategy
going to be and to what extent are we
allowing it to flex
um so do we plan it so that like a pair
of trousers
have i got space to grow just in case or
am i tight now
am i tightening the elastic so hard that
there's no room to grow
and i think that's the first practical
level to do it um
to make sure that there's enough space
and you can you can plan your work your
workspace accordingly
in that way and and that's still tricky
because it's never perfect but
at least it's an informed decision the
more challenging aspect is the cultural
change piece now i actually don't think
that organizations once they've started
changing
they don't go backwards they'll they'll
they're on the path
now they might not get to where we
thought they were going to get to
get to go they might get halfway there
or quarter but they're on that journey
already
um what i've also observed in
organizations that have made changes is
they've aimed for that and they thought
well what if it falls
short let's just kind of plan
accordingly what i've often found
in past examples is they've aimed for
that and actually you give an inch
they take a mile they actually go beyond
so you introduce let's again bring it
back to sharing ratios and numbers and
then something very pragmatic
you say let's introduce a sharing ratio
of 1 to 1.2 120 people can
share 100 desks the other people you can
have more flexibility to work remotely
or what have you
people take that and go oh this is okay
this works um
you re-measure it say six months 12
months after it's been done
and you'll find that the actual sharing
ratio is now more like one to one point
three one to one point four
so the next iteration will be designed
accordingly and once again you'll find
another leap frog happening you can only
measure
what's there today you can't measure
what's in the future so i
i don't actually think it happens but
leadership can be quite nervous about
that obviously
they'll plan for that so they might plan
those trousers to be that bit baggier
than than they need to be that gives
them that sense of comfort
so the response then is well plan to be
able to tighten your trousers quickly
in other words put into your into your
leasing conditions something like an
option to either withdraw early
or to take an additional chunk at some
point should you need it
and kind of build some safety mechanism
into that
okay we have quite a few questions on
metrics actually coming in from our
our virtual viewers um the next one is
has there been a difference
in performance metrics for employees
that are on board
remotely showing
firstly i want to say that i feel for
everybody
who was on board in the remote times
it's a completely
different experience to i was on bottom
physically i know
people i know things and now we are in
virtual right so i really feel for them
um i think the expectation
of the role hasn't changed and therefore
the metrics of output hasn't changed
right
but the metrics of maybe
um or the delivery of the onboarding is
has
of course the mechanism has changed
right so for virtually
before you need it you need a much more
uh organized
uh sharepoint or files before compared
to before right because you
you can just point things out right you
need to be a lot more organized so i
think the process of onboarding has
changed
but i would say that the metric have i
changed the metric for
um hey you were on board it during the
pandemic and you would be on board
before the pandemic
and today you have two different metrics
there's the problems we haven't done
that
and i don't i'm thinking with the
premise of the question right
i don't think that it also
should the premise of it is that
is the person who onboarded in the in
the remote setting are they
disadvantaged versus this other person
and therefore
the metric you fulfill that i think a
company and certainly we do
challenge ourselves at how do we make
sure that the remote
person or the person or motor in remote
time is able to be supported and comes
up to what is expected of the role
versus having uh two class of citizens
if you will
um that that wouldn't sit with our
culture okay
anybody would like to add i'm just
wondering if i mean i
i i would have the same question like
it's a great question
um how does uh let's take a hypothetical
fresh graduate who's just been on board
and internet corporate
um how long did that first graduate take
to become a
contributing member of the organization
in a pre-covered regular come to the
office five days a week
scenario and how long does it take that
same fresh graduate to acculturate
and become a productive member of the
team in the current environment
i don't know what the answer is i
suspect it's a lot longer
but i don't know anybody
anybody do we have any fresh graduates
in the room here
put your hand up oh we have a fresh can
you
answer that question do you have a sense
i suppose there's like different ways
you can look at it because
if you want to immerse yourself in the
company culture i think
being there presently or being at the
workspace
is a good way to of doing so but online
you might not engage in the culture as
well you might not know what your
superiors want from you
so there's that fine balance to like
look at
and how do you feel you've been
acculturated into your organization
well it's worked i've been lucky well
lucky or not it's up to your opinion but
since i started work i've been coming in
full-time five days a week
and in that sense it's helped me
acclimatize easier to know what the
your bosses want from you and i think in
that sense it's really helped me
acclimatize a lot better overall
um i can't say i can't give an
answer for if i wasn't if i was working
online or working from home
that's just my perspective and it's
going to be difficult to do that because
you're going to have to take two
different people
two different people have been in both
situations and comparing contrast i
think it's a challenge
hello uh andrew here i just have a
question in terms of
how do you see kind of remote work
affecting loyalty to a company because
i've seen people who have been onboarded
fully virtual
and it seems like they move faster
because they're just clicking on a
different zoom link
they don't have to change office they
don't have to change lockers
literally it's just the links change in
their calendar
so i'm just wondering have you seen
signs of actually loyalty eroding and
kind of that reflecting in the attrition
rates
or do you anticipate that kind of
changing once we go back to normal
do you want to take that yeah i've seen
you have more data i guess but i can
take that from my
head um the answer is
we haven't seen a significant rate so if
we we obviously measure attrition rates
and
things and regrettable attritions as a
subset
and we haven't noticed that in
particular
right that people who are on board that
said of course it's
relatively recent and the job market's
not great so there are some extenuating
circumstances that might be suppressing
nutrition rates
but i think um the easy the the premise
of it is kind of like what uh
back to was it anapath's question um
which is are you able to give a good
experience
in remote are you able to form the
connection to your company and your
brand
and your culture and that has this
impact on retention which is kind of
like the
the issue that you're facing and i think
companies who are able to do that and i
already our experience is that we are
quite specific on that
um we so far haven't seen it but we are
very intentional yeah so i give example
um many of you might be familiar with
the sg united traineeship
right which the government came up with
and for to support freshgrads and
and and we were in the papers recently
for supporting and we have uh
we took in a badge and we have equal
numbers of fresh grads
um and also made career switches right
and we came in and
and they are coming on board in a
pandemic for sure
and so what we did we looked at it and
they are across the whole organization
and maybe
not everybody we actually try to support
them also as a cohort
right like you do a ma cohort or intern
cohort so there's a program to like
to say that okay you guys come in you're
with managers but there's
a intentional check-in from an
organizational level
on like a monthly um as united how he's
going what's your experience how has it
been
and we do have a coming back to both
their points earlier
we do have a pulse survey we use a
certain platform
that we then pass to check in housing
well-being how you think
and then we're able to then have a hot
heat map of the organization and narrow
down
into things right so so it has to be
that the level of
intention of making sure that whoever is
on board
or remotely or not to be part of the
team to be a contributing
but that we really care for you right if
you don't feel the care then sure
there's no loyalty which is to your
question
right so if we are able to do that both
from a manager level
but a systemic waste at an organization
an intention then that's
how we're approaching it is it really
successful i would say that the data is
not available yet because it's so new
right so we're um so but we'll see but
that's just to share our approach
i think i think there's a really good
point there though is it brings us back
to that culture
care equals culture engagement equals
culture
good managers equal culture and culture
is the differentiator which is the point
we were making earlier
um it shows how important culture
and nurturing looking after your culture
how much how important that is in this
new world that we're in it's
it may have been a second thought it may
have happened naturally before now it's
something we really need to look after
it has to be a lot more intentional at
this point yes okay we have time for one
more question
yes
hi it's a vivek here from singtel um
so i mean i know a lot of people are
calling it you know
office has been disrupted but i really
call it
an accelerator um the crisis has been an
accelerator of uh you know the
technology was lagging behind but do you
think
industry is well prepared to take the
leap into the next
stage of technology or will it take
another crisis
to come through and then the com then
industry moves into the next
phase of uh you know sort of a more
collaborative work
and the reason i bring this up is
because i was reading this research
by an insead professor
the whole our mind is not able to focus
on zoom
because we are looking at a 2d image and
we cannot read the body language
of the people on the other side so that
really uh you know brings into picture
do are we lagging behind in terms of
artificial reality do we need that
to bring into uh industry bring into
workplace
so my question really is are we really
prepared for that
next leap or is it going to be another
crisis that will you know
push to that extent maybe i'll direct
this question to
andy so
it's a good question i don't think we
are prepared for this one because um
at the moment a lot of companies are
still struggling to catch up with the
status quo
um i don't know whether people are
thinking way ahead uh what what could
happen next over there
but the point that you are mentioning i
think we all feel it right
we all don't feel that zoom meetings are
as effective as uh
in-person face-to-face meetings over
there so there's something lacking over
there which
is creating gaps and this has to be
addressed
and um current technology can only close
some of the gaps but not all of it
anybody else said i i think the
technology
is not lagging behind as far as we think
it is um i think what's lagging behind
is our behaviors our own ability
to deal with the change um i think or to
deal with the technology for that matter
i'm not saying the technology is perfect
not by a long shot but
our ability to say to sit there and go
like i'm in the zoom meeting
let me concentrate that's what i'm
finding incredibly difficult
like oh i've got three screens up and
i'm listening to the zoom meeting there
oh i just received an email let me let
me cope with that
hang on what what did you just say and
and suddenly that
it's a kind of internal thing uh and one
can get very quickly overwhelmed by
saying well if i
concentrate on this i'll miss out on
emails and so you
we are getting overloaded we're getting
uh
we're losing the ability to to kind of
manage our own i am i don't know about
anybody else
but you know i think it's i think the
problem is with us so we need to either
train ourselves or be trained we need to
learn a whole new skill set
um we've only had to do this for the
last 12 months and that's not a long
time
and if you've been working in the
industry for what 25 30 years
making that change is that much harder
someone introduces teams and i'd like
did you send me a team's message or an
email message where do i find the
blasted file
it's driving me nuts okay and it's new
set of skills
that is maybe where the technology is
lagging but it's a combination of things
i don't know yeah um
it's funny because i'm thinking of the
premise of your question right
and the the what it's coming up with is
like there is a
there's a fundamental gap in terms of
how ready we are as human beings working
and available technologies which is and
and i and i agree with mark a lot of it
is tested with humans like
human psychology and how we respond and
how we build a team
um i contrast this to maybe um
youngest wife i have a nine-year-old
daughter and she has a
some you know their home-based learning
and their zoom calls and stuff
and i and there's less resistance
because there's less
building things i mean i i don't want to
be a teacher teaching
20 kids on zoom right but it is this
mayhem
but somehow they're able to navigate
there and they're able to do it right so
is that a
level of understanding yes and is it an
understanding
at the end to be able to assume fatigue
is a real thing
right and do we then recognize that as a
way of working that
buffers that within short breaks in
between rather than back to back the
whole day
are we able to make sure that the zoo
meeting has
has a lot more emotional rapport
building connections
in the beginning before you go into the
work task
there's a number of things that i think
that is human behavior
and work practice and cultural practices
and they say what culture what culture
in that sense
that can that can be balanced right so i
don't think it's a pure technology piece
but can technology be harnessed to give
nudges our technology be able to do
these things
right now in in prudential if i set a
one hour meeting i get a pop-up and i'll
look to say that
hey meeting should be 45 minutes to give
you a buffer
you know so that all these kind of
things you could harness existing
technologies
if we understand um how how people work
right so i think
leaders in organizations have to be much
more
clearer on the human uh psychology human
dimension human
i say i'm a certified uh hypnotherapist
and i tell you when i do that there was
a side thing i never thought that some
of the principles that i learned that
would be applicable at work but
understanding unconsciousness i
understand how that works and the
subconscious works actually is
tremendously
important as a leader today in this
world right so
so i don't think it's a pure technology
piece if i could share
okay and that's all we have time for um
i want to thank
the three of you and some very very
experienced speakers for spending
your evening with us today i think we
delved into a lot of topics
today about leadership trust
rigorous communication that has to be
done across the
companies and throughout the companies
we've also
touched on a little bit about technology
as well so i really hope that this
session was as
enriching and meaningful to you as it
was for me let me hand over this time to
valentina
thank you very much angelina and dear
speakers thank you so much
for your very valuable insights thank
you also to you
for coming in today and those online
thank you so much